ciao a tutti oggi challenge slime
riempire ho fatte due scatole di lime e
poi dentro mettiamo un sacco di sorprese
che offrendo certo pia o pescare quelle
sorprese in ordine però ad esempio forse
il numero multiple sqare e la brutta
sorpresa per sbaglio bensì nord la foto
che non è la punta sorprenda ovviamente
non bisogna guardare da tiratori a
inverso ground ed evidente profili
vediamo chi visse riuscendo a trovare
più sorpreso esprima una volta che
troviamo la sorpresa la possiamo coprire
continua vediamo se volete vedere altre
sale dalle persone rimaste salento
stiamo e scrivete su freni come chicche
challenge vorreste vedere e siete prodi
mettetevi cosi e siamo food
ok abbiamo tre contenitori d'acqua
ora siamo come si forma che raffredda
[Musica]
allora mettiamole mettere biometal è un
posto che non cresca troppo sono stato
tutto bellissimo
[Musica]
andiamo mettere l'altro guardate che
strano sta crescendo da sotto vedete che
sta crescendo sempre di più lo slime è
stranissimo che sono votate su
libertiamo le mani dentro come
bellissimo set
succede come si mischiano vestito il
colore se è un bellissimo effetto wow
sempre che ci siamo una nuvola the go
che effetto bellissimo oggi alle
sfumature tra viola e celeste sembra un
dipinto in modo magia live come sta
scendendo notte è bellissimo per
[Musica]
guardare è un brano niente sacchetto
fiore è bravissimo si vedono in
trasparenza perché sono il calo rimane
insomma
comunque invitato ok allora ora dovranno
chiudere gli occhi tra l'altro stupro
indossato questo accordo e rinfrescante
dobbiamo chiudere gli occhi e cercare la
busta sorprenda 321 mia impresa che come
ha fatto
eppure gli otto buste la brutta sorpresa
questa come se non fossimo presa di
distanza ok pensare aveva capito che
devo fare allora
tirava fuori tutta guardare ed attuare
possono quindi largo respiro che apriamo
gli occhi ti presentavi sorpresa la fuga
ed i portali bifore un ragazzo e la mia
sono i gattini vellutati
ma è meglio stare a fianco dopo sono le
ringhiere sulla ricchezza anche se
vorrebbe subito la seconda volta che
dobbiamo trovare e il kinder sorpresa al
32 un occhio degli occhi
cosa sarà più facile trovato nome
riconosciuto subito le cose più piccole
sono più difficili da trovare
perché quelle piccole infatti si fa si è
troppo divertente soprano e fresco ok se
devo hanno trovato anche a 3 2 1 0
azzurro ma saprete dare terza dobbiamo
trovarlo squizzi che tra le più facili
prede
tieni gli occhi di fronte a questo
perché è d'oro da provare
guardavamo io
quanti metri non si vedono l'ostica
dell'angola che tappezza vediamo sì qui
si serie affitto lì il flight a nostra
volta la giusta la palazzina è diventato
blu nome ci sono la busta e rovinate per
sempre
magari più che altro che ha preso e
colore blu ma come le mie mani devo dire
che non era il mio scritti che andiamo
da parla chiaro che cosa c'è da soprano
ciao mamma per riempirsi questo di slime
è chiuso ma un grumo di stiamo l'ultima
cosa e può essere o una principessa o un
una sorpresa lo festeggi piccola per me
quindi per questo che il flop per la
canapa che tonda figlia trovata la
bicicletta
letta per la vinci questo stando a
respirare nell'acqua bella questa è una
bomba
bene sto pensando sia dentro sia una
sorpresa hanno appena ricordate
ve la ricordate questo volevo già fatta
vedere in un big in cui per scavo le
cose con l'ac romancing l'acchiappa
brehme è in pratica fissione e dentro
c'è una sorpresa l'on
quindi anche quello che diamo
direttamente dello strike t vediamo come
diventa allora apriamo la bas bond
vediamo se si si sta aprendo tra il coso
con il fogliettino che tutto bagnato poi
apriamo il prossimo strà e più brutti
buttiamo sly vediamo più posizione a chi
sa c'è dappertutto sono le bolle ma è
sprofondata
guardate sta attrezzando ma non colora o
molto proviamo a metterla dallo slang di
vitale strano ora siccome è molto denso
le bolle salgono lentamente
eccola che strane come se sia stata
inglobata nella gelatina ma ci siamo
quasi al secondo strato poi faccio cena
a sorpresa cercando da mezz'ora la
sorpresa al nostro paese dopo che si è
sciolta la bat bob ma non approviamo
non capiamo se sia perché magari perché
piccolissima e quindi è molto più
difficile da trovare oppure non c'era
proprio dentro perché io contro l'altro
la fatto poco mentre si
scioglieva e niente disputato pure
niente corona giustifica questa offerta
di questa sì che è un rock sound feed
e c'è sempre un charlie dentro ed entra
possibile che non ci sia niente dentro
però non ci proviamo niente quindi forse
si sono sbagliati ha postato da
crederete fa galleggiare non è però è un
pezzo di carta non è quello ok non
abbiamo trovato purtroppo lo capisco
come che possibile
comunque andiamo a farle un boxing delle
cose che abbiamo mandato e le mette male
gli scrissi vediamo se riusciamo a
registrarli stupendo questi pop corn
sono così lunedì unitamente questo
nemico che ha preso lui e tanti noi
giocate apposta in piazze come ti ha
fatto io ci ho provato ad orazio qualche
volta sono grato di porno 10 secondi del
massimo andretta prossimo ad un ovetto
kinder ero quasi rifatto il look hippy
perrucchetti che definisce la carina
invece ore lunghissime che fa fare il
bagno con il salvagente hello kitty con
il salvagente che carino il nuovo metro
di sticker proprio le principesse disney
ok io poi il resto dai aspetta aspetta
secondo te chi è secondo me è arrivato
dopo ci sono il boss si appella
mi piace a voi quale fece questa piace
di me se un po barchitta se lette sembra
cenerentola in acqua molto bene qua che
carolina e sa anche il download penso
che sia falso
eccola qua cenerentola è sopravvissuta
online ma almeno sopravvivi sta ora
ultimo sul prezzo da staffetta primato
il mio gattino detto pro vissuto anche
capirlo bigliettini gatto problema che
carino erano sembrate era bianco ed è
diventato blu con lo slime perché mentre
best regards è anche un altro gatto blu
ed ente riusciamo a vedere l'immagine
parte che siamo a capire se no romeo era
già blues che moro melo e the blue
cappellino 8 dai altri non vedevi l'ora
vediamo un po
[Musica]
la famiglia questo grosso norme non solo
settimi e una figurina in persona cosa a
parti gatto 59 80 capi 96 80 a impieghi
iniziano a sentire anzi questa c'è
un'altra cosa del costo zero che cosa
adesso ci sono delle vere carte
quello che cerchiamo di cristo card
peccato di fortuna è sicuramente utile e
finanza come si mette e che bene anche
team è stato definito così proprio
ristoro principio aggiunto che siamo
capiti lo sa bene tenere presente i
bambini avvitare iscrivetevi il commento
delle stoviglie che dire di piu se
potesse sapere se vi è piaciuto
petacciatese vorreste veder neanche la
sua bella e civile light andremo fanno
un'altra sistema che avrebbe lasciamo
fatto altro caselline su cui cliccare
per vedere i prossimi video le case su
quella che preferite e buona visione
cosa